[Música]
votar nos botar boa tarde a todos
a amm mais gostava de agradecer da ótv
que a organização por convite para
postar aqui pra mim facto um privilégio
meu nome com seca
eu sou antes de mais pai de uma filha
linda cristal e só empresário tenho de o
facto ceo de uma empresa que se chamará
tronics vamos falar um pouquinho dela
sou surfista facto tamanho apaixonado eu
todas as semanas praticamente todo ano
faço faz earth adoro e sou
vice-presidente é de uma delegação da
cruz vermelha portuguesa enquanto
enquanto voluntário na prática aquilo
que eu tinha que fazer foi falar de
forma muito clara que o que considero
tendo em conta a minha experiência é que
o considera o vosso papel nas tiradas do
sul inscritos em portugal no porto santa
maria da feira na nossa comunidade local
e é isso que vou fazer usar seguida
voltou a falar mesmo sobre isso que
acredito que consigo hoje mudar a nossa
vida no que respeita aquilo que é o
vosso papel
vamos forma muito forte e equívoca dizer
o século xxi será o vosso papel e de
fato é que o que eu considero voz que é
o nosso papel e que o que é mesmo o
vosso papel é basicamente não faça
melhor
basicamente se achavam que eu ia falar
sobre o hospital estão totalmente
enganados e não precisa nada com a voz o
papel de paterna isso e nos órgãos opôs
transmitir a minha vida é altamente
empresarial trabalho só e portanto não
faço a mínima ideia exacta rosa papel se
pegaram 15 a responder
esqueçam a esfinge pioneiro da vossa
vida forma mais séria é uma coisa que eu
saísse pessoa ao longo da minha vida é
qual é o meu papel e na prática isso
também vos venho aqui passarem a contar
um pouco da minha história de vida é e
aquilo que considero que foi um papel
tel
o hotel dias de hoje é que eu considero
que é hoje é o meu papel importante que
têm na nossa sociedade é combinado onde
estou inserido muito bem pra isso é eu
usei ficar uma imagem de todos nós
conhecemos essa imagem passa a vida a
estar no nas redes sociais no facebook é
mais em dois velhos para cima do sucesso
a parte mais caminho próprio a chegar é
que não seja da vossa opinião mas aquilo
que eu nunca vi nos facebooks foi isto
aplicavam um caso real
eu sinceramente nunca vi e na prática é
isso que eu vim aqui fazer convosco é
como minha história aplicará esta
metáfora do do iceberg
vamos falar um pouquinho agora sobre a
parte de cima é é para pressionar
enquanto sucesso é que as pessoas gostam
de ver
e por falar do meu percurso até chegar a
isso mesmo sucesso
o meu sucesso está no sucesso está muito
ligado ao pronex autonation empresa que
eu criei em 2004 é uma empresa muito
conhecida atualmente no mercado
português já entrou finalmente nós somos
mais de 40 pessoas atualmente está vamos
faturar mais de 4 milhões de euros é nós
temos a nossa senhora que no norte no
concelho da trofa e depois temos
ligações entre madrid e lisboa é uma
empresa que esse aumento está ligado a
algumas áreas de negócio mas por exemplo
para ter uma pequena do que aquela é nós
somos fabricantes de tintas autocolantes
estamos no sítio certo até nós pregamos
em bobinas de papel e transformamos das
etiquetas de códigos vagas por exemplo
que todos nós temos temos acesso nosso
piada e depois outra é muito forte somos
somos fabricantes de software fábrica de
software para gestão de armazém e
logística temos software austrália está
a funcionar na malásia na online no
brasil os pais em portugal com com muita
força mas acima de tudo estamos muito
ligada à tecnologia do calvário que está
por trás daquilo que nós fizemos com as
barrinhas preto e branco
nós estamos o que produzimos muita
tecnologia está farto ligada
decore com várias subidas muito
conhecidos como é passarmos a verdade de
prêmios nós temos um orgulho enorme se
todos os anos temos carros de prêmios é
fantástico para nós ver o nosso trabalho
reconhecido é fabuloso
já tivemos um prego um prémio europeu
somos melhores empresas para trabalhar
inclusive para a próxima semana voltarei
em lisboa se de mais um prêmio melhores
empresas para trabalhar em portugal que
é fantástico
somos empresas uma das empresas mais
feliz para trabalhar pmse cpma líder há
vários anos é do nosso conhecimento vai
muito também todos os prêmios que nós
vamos acumulando ao longo do rali pois
daqui e vai também muita visão por trás
vista regionais que vão falando sempre
sobre altamente isso acaba por cruzar
muito no treinando e faz pra nós é
fantástico ver o nosso trabalho
reconhecido é só entra mesmo muito bem
outra questão que nós consideramos que é
o papel das empresas atualmente é
responsabilidade social
estamos fundamental isso é algo que está
na nossa é na vários anos que todos os
anos fazemos iniciativa se você olhar
social
fazemos muitas equipes falar sobre uma
ter mais impacto também temos previsão
os pistas jornais etc
o projeto fala a portugal marés podem
ver no site depois ela projeto
totalmente sem fins lucrativos que no
seu corpo basicamente não quer promover
duas coisas interligadas entre si uma o
produto português pessoense que sabemos
que existem em portugal e as empresas
portuguesas anos com isso vamos
impulsionar a economia vamos impulsionar
o emprego que tanto necessitamos em em
portugal por outro aluno mas não menos
importante este projeto visa promover
aquilo que nós achamos também que é o
suplente capital humano que existe em
portugal ao tronics um grande exemplo
isso nós temos o capital humano de
influência dentro do portas e que
estamos em portugal
isso também é fantástica e cá este
projecto acaba por tentar impulsionar
para que às vezes suas pressiona que
somos mesmo bons eu tenho atualmente
mais de 200 empresas aderentes este este
projeto
destaco é mesmo muito bem é muito temos
que é o grande papel das empresas
desenvolver a funcionar um pouco daquilo
que servem dessa mesma sociedade e isso
através da responsabilidade que achamos
que tem que ter muito bem vamos falar da
parte do vasto iceberg como é que tudo
isso foi possível
eu sou grande fados gato preto ea uns
cats deus que eu acho imensa piada que
eu risos aí tal padrão nos protestos é
que somos cinco coisas
trabalho trabalho trabalho trabalho e
trabalho e eu concordo com inteiramente
em outro grande falou eu faço na minha
vida também é capa capital bastante
sucesso
tenho consciência que sempre trabalhei
muito para atingir o sucesso
é como disse conforme naturalmente a
minha vida começa com uma parte de
empreendedorismo
se é que se pode chamar assim a fazer
pirataria e com 89 anos mais ou menos no
tempo dos petros está máx gravava
cassete vídeo aos meus amigos e
conhecidos de gravar umas massas com
isso o fato aos 13 anos de idade
a minha família tinha poucos postos e eu
só tem que ser tratada escola sai da
escola e vou e vou trabalhar em um
futuro melhor para para uma oficina de
automóveis
na prática a nova casa o youtube era um
livro ou até dos casos proview viável
aquela porcaria
estava mesmo aquilo mas do fato de uma
grande motivação é essa motivação
chamava se a minha mãe ea forma como ela
motivar a todos os parceiros a câmera
com um chinelo velho o que era
fantástica levantava da cama com uma
rapidez como a vontade de trabalhar
rosa foi sempre a minha mãe naquela quer
que esteja tem orgulho enorme nela mas
pronto eram outros tempos eu saí daquela
oficina como disse eu vi aquilo e vou
trabalhar para uma empresa no ramo
têxtil
esta empresa eu vou trabalhar atrás do
horário normal mas o mal se questiona o
que no turno noturno e navas bastante
mas naquela altura fará 20 e tal anos
atrás do paço automaticamente para parar
o turno da noite que o crime jamais
massa e trabalhava das 11 da noite às 7
da manhã era duro aqui o auto cuidado
que eu tinha 14 anos e amélia puxava a
as situações que tenham suas amigas que
dizem ah e tal aí mora chegar ao
trabalho
posso dizer que naquela altura nova
técnica dos transportes públicos e de
comandar um praça pet nova três horas a
chegar no local o trabalho e quando sair
a sentença amanhã uma nova cinco horas
cada casa e voltava tudo outra vez
passar algumas horas então como
desenhado por muito tempo no trânsito
para atuar o shopping na muito bem é que
também nesta empresa edson santos que eu
tenho na altura não havia muita escola
de vagas quer em portugal jazz via mas
com pouca frequência esta empresa que
teve o primeiro contato com qualquer
tecnologia quatro vagas e facto nascem
uma paixão que ainda hoje é espelhado
daquilo que é o tronics atualmente a
partir daí sair dessa empresa vou
trabalhar como serralheiro numa outra
empresa ligada também à área isto é
basicamente prova em bocados r
transformado em novas peças para
indústria têxtil torcida é engatado nota
nossa profissão certa forma ligados para
mecânico de máquina de costura eu
colocava uma empresa de vila do conde
responsável por mais de 300 máquinas
ligado à repressão de máquinas de
costura para um cara que é curioso que
ainda hoje na euronext nós temos
processo de produção de etiquetas que
tem muitíssima mecânica e ainda hoje ou
problemas que aprendi tudo que passei
por essa fase de buscar em máquinas de
costura é e aprendi muito isso mesmo e
outro novo tento também não gostei que a
área tecnológica que não estou hoje
gostei muito dessa área eu passo por um
técnico de informática de 40 social
vendas gestor de uma empresa é até carro
como diretor de compras de uma empresa
também obrigada certa forma área
tecnológica numa e passa ali como
empregado de mesa é e ele será também a
mais umas massas
e vou começar a trabalhar ao sábado e ao
domingo é como entrar mesmo trabalha há
cinco anos como funcionário de um
restaurante na prática servia casamento
só sábado eo mix via as mesas
curiosamente também há pessoas que dizem
é para estarmos a fia 56 casamentos
participantes ao paredão
já o desafia 200 casamentos desde a vida
toda por muito que andar muito bem
no final do estudo desmontar o mix é que
nessa altura o nexus one não
microempresa que nas do zero
praticamente até o curso que tá aí que
teve que até que o que ela é
atualmente hoje muito bem o que eu acho
pessoalmente também é importante e que
foi o meu papel foi é ter uma capacidade
enorme de perceber que para ter sucesso
é a busca por formação e informação é
fundamental sempre tanto que passados
dez anos ao conectar criado totalmente a
minha zona de conforto empresa faturava
mais três milhões de euros
eu decidi zona de conforto e vou tirar
um sonho que tinha eu vou concretizar um
sonho que tenho e quero tirar uma
licenciatura ou terá o êxito em gestão
de marketing
já a campanha de estruturas sociais
estão estudando marketing
com isso quero dizer o que é fundamental
para o sucesso é seja para alcançar ou
para se manter lá a busca constante por
formação por mais informação por por
melhor informação já que a minha
licenciatura já estou numa pós graduação
por exemplo neste momento é tanto mesmo
quando está no sucesso é importante sair
da zona de conforto quando retirarem a
assinatura foi muito duro trabalhar
durante o dia e à noite estudar foi
duríssimo para mim pensar mas não ia ser
brutal
existem muitas vezes mas parece
concretize a concretizar os nossos
sonhos é preciso ser presidenta deve
passar também uma mensagem muito clara
que é preciso arriscar e eu vou chegar
onde cheguei
nós vemos a parte de cima do mais velho
de pescar muitíssimas vezes é necessário
saber arriscar eu sou surfista
adoro surfar mas tem a consciência que
toda vez que o pomar a coisa pode correr
mal e possa inclusive por minha vida em
risco
mas
o que eu gosto então se aquilo que gosto
tem como ler todas as informações que eu
possa ter
e com isso e pó e para o mar correndo -
ou menos risco possível mas eu só quero
uma onda tem que provar
eu acho que mesmo na vida é exatamente
igual nós temos que buscar só é possível
chegar ao sucesso seus carros em treinar
os momentos da minha vida da nossa vida
de outra forma
na minha opinião está mesmo muito
complicado se vemos sempre nossa zona de
conforto muito bem dizer o seguinte
realiza sonhos têm medo de errar
eu acho isso um erro o tempo é o meu
caso tenho sucesso time enquanto sol
enquanto empresário eu errei 500 mil
vezes e por chegar onde vocês venham
conseguem ser usada para cima do iceberg
eu tenho é muitas vezes como te muito
estimo centro da minha vila e portanto
dizer o que temos que aprender com esses
erros e hoje faz coisas corretamente
porque já como t já contidos no passado
dessas mesmas coisas de outra forma não
é possível a pessoa tenha uma disputa em
errar mas é perfeitamente natural irá
construir um onze com o trampa é a
propósito os tubarões que eu considero
grosso todas aquelas pessoas que vão
apanhar por vosso caminho vão dizer que
não vai ser possível que nunca e não vai
acontecer que vão existir 500 mil
dificuldades e os obstáculos que vão ter
que passar isso tubarões todos os
obstáculos vão ter que passar na nossa
vida para atingir o sucesso por onde
você tem que ter resiliência suficiente
para que ir e voltar a levantar e
enfrentar as coisas da melhor forma só
assim é que é possível chegar ao sucesso
é trabalho de equipa e isso também é uma
mensagem que você queria passar
fundamental no meu caso tenho por
exemplo minha irmã
desde o primeiro dia do autor o nicks o
meu avô enquanto equipa ela é sócia
também da ônix é desde o primeiro dia
que nós somos uma equipa fabulosa e
claramente juntos 15 mais fortes e mais
um casal tronics automax a que parte do
sucesso que vocês viram ela só existe
porque eu tenho uma equipa fantástica de
pessoas a trabalhar comigo outra forma
sozinhos e sinto muito mais doloroso
vocês vão cair muito mais vezes que eu
quero dizer com isto é justiça
as pessoas querem acreditar no sucesso e
eu sozinho tem esses desafios luta que
única coisa que conta e continuar a ter
uma micro na empresa é faturar 100 mil
euros por ano e nunca iria se lhe juntar
100 mil está nas pessoas é na minha
opinião sempre o melhor é caminho
sinalizado quase dizendo qual é que o
que considero que o meu papel nos dias
dois e basicamente um papel é gerir
equipas e eu girei equipas não é
altamente por exemplo andar do melhor
que consigo dá nos motivação da de
ferramentas para eles fazerem todos os
dias mais e melhor é para que pare com
isso e consegui aqui o que que é o meu
sonho que é ter mais inovação que mais
de pressão criar produtos criar produtos
com diferenciação e com isto e para
aquilo que também é importante portugal
para nós é muito pequenino que buscar lá
fora já estamos em espanha já estamos em
alguns países a vender produtos mas
queremos tranqüilizar e isso é de certa
forma que o que é o meu papel 12 é
penalizar esta equipa porque todas estas
estas sonhos possam possam realizar
enquanto meu papel pessoalmente também
considero que tem obrigação de devolver
à sociedade aquilo que ela que ela mas
anualmente então eu tento fazer é no
aumento ponto de vista do voluntariado
ponto estamos consolidados se ao passar
para a sociedade sempre é um pouco
daquilo que ela morar
o voluntariado é muito muito importante
na minha vida enquanto o meu papel e
considero que é fundamental finaliza
dizer que é no ligamento vocês esta
questão do iceberg
podemos usar as roupas todas quisermos
depende unicamente de vocês é construir
o vosso vosso próprio iceberg chegarem
ao sucesso tal como nos que muita gente
chega
zé carlos é o maior sucesso espero mesmo
que consigam o vosso esférico mais
rápido possível e com maior sucesso
possível é agradecer uma vez mais a
telex e obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]